i
am infinity
i am the infinitude
eternally expressing itself
this reality is an expression
of that infinitude
know thyself
the delphic maxim written
on the top of the temple of apollo at
two thousand five hundred years ago
know thyself as infinity
know thyself as source
eternally expressing itself
in this reality is one appearance
of that infinitude
no beginning no end
in sanskrit the word amkara
is so profoundly important as it relates
to
identity
the um is like the
om is the i
the very changeless
the very unmanifested the very truth of
your source
of your infinitude
and then the kara is the association
of that eternal i
with any created thing
and that's the formation
of the ego i
am the body
i am this thought
i am this emotion i am this
feeling
falling into the illusion of
identifying with the clouds
rather than the sky of the
eye the eternal eye
that is shared among us all
in which the
clouds that are transient
appear and disappear
the very i am the body
is ignorance
that is avidya
now vidya knowledge
moksha liberation
nirvana blown out
sahaja enlightenment
becoming a kyani
becoming buddha the awakened one
is to recognize yourself as not the body
is to recognize this as a dreamed
creation design as an appearance
of infinity
neti neti not this not that
i am not the body i am not this
cloud of thought
use the breath
increase the subtlety
to recognize i am awareness
not the body i am the sky
the eternal shared sky of awareness
and just like that the absolutes
gps callback the
parable of the prodigal son
is kicking in more and more
the truest thing about you is that
seeking impulse to
know thyself to know your true nature
so the identity shifted away from i am
the body
to i am awareness
i am the very sky in which the clouds of
experience
appear and disappear
that sky of awareness
is shared among us all
it is eternal
the witness the observer
just like in our dreams at night
when we simulate out an environment
and the observer exploring
that dream ends the next stream begins
again
the observer what is
same across the dreams observation
the witness awareness the
i ask yourself
what is it
and then we get even more subtle
we begin to pluck even this
last thorn of awareness
out
and recognize ourselves as
the ineffable
the attributeless and the
agentless absolute
the nerguna brahmin the brahmana without
attributes
that's what adi shankara meant
1300 years ago
the atman this
is the near guna brahmin
the brahmana without attributes
advaita
not to
i and my father are one john 10
i am source
i am infinity i
am that
eternally expressing itself
and this is about one
appearance
all of us contribute
a unique firework
in this appearance of infinity
as much as the
individuation is a dreamed
illusion it is also
the unique expression of
infinity a
contributory firework
in this dream creation design a unique
gift to bring civilization
i am that i am
infinity i am source
abide as infinity
re-baseline your identity
from i am the body
to i am awareness to i
am infinity i am
beyond everything and nothing
i am that
thank you